MALE SPEAKER: OK so
here's the wireframe
for the authentication flow,
which is really simple.
They just put in their
username or their email.
They need a strong password
to protect their data.
They have capital letters,
numbers, punctuation--
basic stuff-- minimum length
of password, no usernames,
can't have them the same.
They have no common words.
If they get it wrong, a big
red X. They get it right,
they get a nice green
check right there,
and then they login.
Simple.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Why
don't we use Smart Lock?
[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm Eiji.
Let me show you
what is Smart Lock.
Smart Lock makes
authenticating into devices,
websites, and apps easier,
faster, and more secure.
Among other Smart Lock features,
Smart Lock for Passwords
unlock your websites
and apps using passwords
stored in the cloud when
Chrome or Android is signed
in with a Google account.
Let's have a closer
look at how it works.
Let's say you operate
a website that
uses usernames and passwords
to authenticate users.
Once a user is signed in
to your website on Chrome,
Smart Lock can save the
credentials for your user
so they don't need to remember
the password next time they
visit your site using Chrome.
And because Smart Lock
syncs to the cloud,
the user's credentials
to your site
are available on other devices.
It's worked this way
across devices in Chrome
for some time.
But today [INAUDIBLE]
the credentials
are also available to the apps
on the users' Android devices.
This means that
Smart Lock enabled
apps can now retrieve the user's
safety credential information
and automatically
sign in the user.
This also works in reverse.
If a user starts with
authenticating on your Android
app, your website can also
retrieve the user's credential
information.
Let's take a closer
look how you can
enable Smart Lock for
Passwords on your Android app.
Before you start
coding, make sure you
have added Google Play
services revision 23 or later
as a dependency.
The first thing you
should do is to retrieve
the user's password.
In order to do that, call
AuthCredentialsAPIRequest.
By instantiating a
credential request and call
setSupportPasswordLogin, you
can create username and password
required to authenticate a user.
Note that by calling
setAccountTypes,
you can query [? predicted ?]
logins as well.
The result will be written as
a callback with a Credential
Request Result as the argument.
By calling getStatus()
you can get its status.
If the status
indicates success, that
means there's only one
credential information
associated with
the Google account.
In that case, call
get Credential
to obtain actual
credential information
and proceed with
signing in the user.
Otherwise let the user manually
sign in and save the credential
information.
In order to save the
credential information,
call Auth.CredentialsApi.save().
Save the credential information
can be created by instantiating
a Credential object, then
calling setPassword(...).
If you're running a web
version of the same app,
make sure to link the
domain to your app.
In order to do that,
verify the domain
using Google Search Console.
Then link your app to the domain
using Google Play Developer
Console.
Smart Lock for passwords
removes friction
from your existing
authentication system
by automatically signing
in users across devices.
Once your user saves a
password to Smart Lock,
they can skip entering
their credentials
to access your app or site on
all of their Chrome and Android
devices.
We are working on Smart
Lock for Passwords
APIs on other platforms, too.
To keep updated and learn more
about Smart Lock for Passwords,
head over to this document.
I'm looking forward
to seeing you
develop apps that are
personalized, yet low friction.
[ERASING]
MALE SPEAKER 2: Simple!
[MUSIC]